brand new poll that showed that more and
more americans
are rethinking what happened on 9 11 and
increasingly more people are saying they
do not believe the government's version
of events
[Music]
greetings and peace welcome to the dean
shaw subscribe if you haven't already
now it's a very sad reality that
whenever
911 is mentioned somehow islam and
muslims
has to get brought up or people in the
back of their mind are thinking okay
islam
had something to do with it motivating
muslims
hell no when you study and this is what
really triggered me
to really get out there and try to
educate people on the purpose of life on
islam
and all clear these misconceptions
because the more i started to study
islam
i saw that it promoted peace justice
love and mercy all of the opposite
things that many of these radical
hate fear mongering
individuals who are out there spewing
this crazy stuff
to have nothing to do with islam but now
they're over
look check it out my next guest he goes
even further
and says muslims had nothing to do with
9 11.
and candidly wouldn't only fringe people
still question
what happened on 9 11 well perhaps not
today we're going to release to you
results of a brand new poll that show
that more and more americans
are rethinking what happened on 9 11.
along with
three get this two thousand architects
and engineers have cited evidence
proving that the buildings were brought
down in control of demolition
plus architects and engineers and 911
family members now there are more than
1500
architects and engineers who say that it
could not have been brought
down by office fires they are backed by
9 11 family members who are calling for
an
independent unbiased investigation
that's what we're going to be talking
about this week's show now
my question is to you is it is it wrong
to ask
questions and want answers to these
questions that's what we're going to be
talking about on
this week's exciting show don't go
anywhere
we'll be right back
[Music]
peace be with you how are you sir thank
you peace be with you too
you have dedicated your whole life
to this cause well at least since 1990
since
1990 you've dedicated the majority of
your time your you put everything almost
on the line i mean this is to go against
the grain
yeah i was fully employed as a salary
engineer i had an excellent job i have
quit that to go into consulting
and because of my outspokenness the
consulting opportunities became fewer
so since 1990 till about the present
this is what i've been doing what's the
first thing that you will say to someone
who will say that people who are asking
questions about this
are crazy and deranged have you ever
been confronted like this
oh yeah the the first thing i get is
it's a conspiracy conspiracy theorist
the definition of a conspiracy is when
two or more people
acting in concert knowingly commit
an offense or or or a crime all right
a misdemeanor or a felony an offense
that is the definition of a conspiracy
was this a conspiracy
absolutely yes it was and those people
need to go
to jail for treason are you
uh no because i don't have a conspiracy
theory
the government does the government's
account of 9 11 is itself a conspiracy
theory
the only problem with that is the facts
don't support the government's theory
i have uh the facts that contradict that
and i've challenged the chairman of the
nightmare commission personally and the
911 commission
lied to the public i mean you cannot be
that stupid you cannot be that stupid
now do do we uh going back to the since
you mentioned the commission
weren't there people like lee hamilton
who was the head of the commission
who said that this was set up from the
beginning to fail so there are all kinds
of reasons
we thought we were set up to fail we got
started late
we had a very short time frame indeed we
had to get it extended
uh we did not have enough money they
were
they were afraid we were going to hang
somebody
that we would point the finger lee and i
write in our book that um
we think the commission in many ways was
set up to fail
because we had not enough money
we didn't have enough time we've been
appointed by the most partisan people in
washington
yes they've written that it was set up
to fail and there's another commissioner
i forget his name from
georgia who resigned saying it's a scam
have you talked to the 9 11 family
members i'm a family member trying to
find out the answers
to the murder of three thousand plus
people
the bottom line is that it needs to be
investigated
properly
please look at architects and engineers
people all around the world
scientists all around the world are
questioning this
and there's some deep deep explaining to
do
we will never heal this country will
never ever
ever forget that day we have to demand
a new investigation i want justice here
and others there's some like what is it
now 3000 plus
scientists engineers architects who are
asking questions also
it took some kind of consciousness
raising on my part before i was willing
to
look at the possibilities and really you
need to go
where the evidence leads as an engineer
i have three degrees in engineering
i signed that petition for architects
and engineers
for 9 11 truth some time ago because the
american people absolutely need
the truth of 9 11. look at the evidence
in fact i'll say this very categorically
any reasonable person who looks at the
evidence that's been brought
forward has got to come away with the
feeling
that something has to be done a real
investigation
has to be put forward people who want
the truth yes
tell us about that yeah i've actually
appeared on
one talk with richard gage architects
and engineers
at another with one of the members of
pilots for 9 11 truth who is
military pilot and we have no
disagreement although
i must say richard gage does not talk
about the pentagon i do
what motivates motivated you to dedicate
so much time to this
well one i did have time between
consulting assignments
second i'm an engineer who was always
curious about
big multidisciplinary problems the first
problem was that when i was working at
oklahoma gas electric
i want to go into the details but i
solved that then at the department of
energy
i managed the us national power grid
study i had 26 teams 150
multi-disciplinary folks working on it
so i always enjoyed large
multi-disciplinary problems and i didn't
approach this to solve 911
it just turned out that i uncovered one
thing which led to something else and
over seven eight years i wrote this book
what are you trying to accomplish
uh just get to the truth without truth
there's no justice
and without justice there's no peace one
thing i can say for sure without a
shadow of a doubt
that because islam has somehow been
brought into this
so this is what we as muslims take
strong exception to
islam doesn't condone but it condemns
acts like this this is was a sad and
tragic incident this has
nothing to do with islam but now we're
going even deeper
you're saying that hold on you know
because somehow they've also said
and muslims uh we we have to take
accountability
let's say there are some deranged
muslims out there some people who are
not
practicing islam properly so you have a
fringe element but now you're going on
top of that and saying
look it wasn't even muslims who did had
anything to do with it yeah
the first thing let me cite one
statistics and this is from the
government
since 9 11. why is our news media
foaming at the mouth when it comes to
stories about islamic terrorists
but not white guy terrorists it's not
because muslims are a bigger threat
in fact between 1980 and 2005
94 percent of all the attempted or
successful terrorist attacks
on u s soil were not carried out by
islamic radicals
but instead by non-muslims mostly white
guys
so then why the obsession islam
is killing of innocent human beings
human life is precious
so inside the u.s there are more muslim
uh
americans killed by non-muslims in this
country
do they blow people up yes christians
every day people walk in the post office
people walk into post offices they walk
into schools that's what columbine i
mean i can do this all day long there's
so
there are so many more examples of
christians
and i happen to be a christian that's
back to this notion of your idealizing
christianity in my mind to my read
there's so many more examples of john of
christians who do that then you could
ever give me examples of muslims who
have done that inside this country where
you live and work
muslim there are more americans killed
by bathtub accidents and deer
b strings bee stings so
of course there are uh muslims that are
doing all kinds of horrible acts but
many of them aren't
inspired by the u.s or actually
cultivated by the us are you aware that
the taliban
when the u.s was still in there fighting
russians
they sent textbooks to the uh to
afghanistan where the
abc that you're used to with a for apple
b for something
banana was replaced by all weapons and
ammunition
and those textbooks were prepared here
in the u.s and sent to afghanistan
so much of the violence
it's not to say there was never violence
but much of it has been exaggerated by
the policy of the west
uh there's a a fireman right now that
we're going to take a clip
and show as i said i had 32 years there
and i was also
a trained fire marshal a fire marshal is
considered an expert witness in court
he's like a forensic detective
he has the power to administer the oath
take testimony and issue a subpoena
that's a lot of power
it was there was an explosion the
building
did come down in complete classical
uh controlled demolition it came down on
its own footprint
there's no question about that as a
matter of fact richard gage from
architects and engineers has
completely handled that from his area of
expertise
never in the history of a world never in
the history of
high-rise skyscrapers has ever
a skyscraper ever come down because of
fire
and i'm talking massive fire and you
know the reason why because
fire does not burn by itself
hot enough to compromise and melt
steel what we had
in the world trade center and i saw
myself
was molten lava like pockets of molten
steel
all right i spent the night on the pile
searching
for bodies and i saw that with my own
eyes
so who are you going to believe are you
going to believe a bunch of
government bureaucrats or my fellow
brothers
which i lost 343 guys that day
this fireman that the people just got to
see is one of the head fireman's i don't
know how how many years
he's uh been on the job and there's many
like him he's saying that this was a
controlled demolition
all by floors that are popping out it
was
what are your thoughts on that oh yeah
i'm no demolition expert but just as an
engineer seeing how the building's
coming
you are also a certified engineer yeah i
have electrical and industrial
engineering degrees
uh there's no way that building can
collapse like that
without ex explosives of some kind
the plane hit somewhat about two-thirds
of the way up on
tower the towers you would expect some
part of the towers to
fall off but you wouldn't expect a
sudden collapse a symmetric collapse
and you wouldn't expect the building
below the point of impact to collapse
hold it right there we're going to take
a break that's the first question that
i'm sure
people are asking how if if um
who calls this now that you needed to
demo the place that means that it would
have to be set up prior
is that correct so that's the first
question and you got a lot more
uh all right we're gonna be right back
with more with uh
enver massoud here on the dean show
don't go anywhere subscribe right now
back here on the dean show first
question could we say
safe to say who set up the demo well we
don't know
we know they're they're the buildings
where
uh their security systems had been
turned off for some time prior to
9 11 that folks were coming in and out
of the building and
that others don't know who they were so
somebody set up the explosives we don't
know who did it
how about there is an interesting
hispanic gentleman
william rodriguez a janitor in the twin
towers for almost
20 years and 9 11 survivor who saved
hundreds of lives on september 11th
by unlocking door after door for
firefighters
and dragging out at least a dozen people
with his own bare hands
known as the last man out before the
world trade center collapsed his
unlikely story had the media glued to
him
like bees to honey who was the janitor
have you met him
rodriguez corresponded with him
rodriguez yes
he was uh he was given many uh
awards and he was with uh was it uh
clinton
clinton that must have been quite an
honor for you it was an experience
definitely and at that time i was
basically uh
loaded to go into politics because they
said this is the guy that we need
to get the latino vote and i was playing
the whole game
of politics because i was doing the
activism and
uh to the moment that i started to ask
questions about what really happened in
911
and you may remember the whole thing
about the 911 commission uh
to be formed and basically became very
active to get it uh basically started
and uh what a surprise i was one of the
person that testified for the 911
commission
and my testimony doesn't appear on the
final report and they were honoring him
and whatnot
push on her bosch honored him but then
somehow the story took a twist
no longer sweetheart of american
broadcasts william now talks mostly to
foreign outlets
the reason his version of 911 differed
from the official scenario
it was the first hijacked plane it was
the first hijacked plane
no hello that was an explosion before
911 before the plane hit the tower
well he was like the last survivor he
was the last survivor
he was in the he says basement b1
when he heard a loud explosion but it
was below him
and he he thought the generator had
blown up
and then a few seconds later he heard he
describes a loud bang at the top
so apparently before whatever struck the
top of the tower
there had been an explosion below him
and
uh yes we've corresponded i don't know
that he's changed the story at all
no uh so that's the first thing and then
you have also
let's go back to these how many is it
now of architects and engineers
for 9 11 truth architects and engineers
who say that it could not have been
brought down
by office fires they are backed by
9 11 family members who are calling for
an
independent unbiased investigation
scientifically you know this is not
possible
um the the uh they're scientists they're
engineers
as an engineer i have three degrees in
engineering
i signed that petition for architects
and engineers
for 9 11 truth some time ago because the
american people
absolutely need the truth of 9 11.
there are pilots there are military
intelligence personnel
there's all kinds of do you know off top
of your head some of the names of these
are big figures you know
well presidential candidates look at the
evidence
in fact i'll say this very categorically
any reasonable person who looks at the
evidence that's been brought forward
has got to come away with the feeling
that something
has to be done a real investigation
has to be put forward so mr mr bowman
who was headed up to the so-called star
wars
program under president reagan he
questioned that he
he was a presidential candidate a few
years ago uh
wesley clark whom i met and i actually
handed him this book uh i met him at
george
washington george georgetown university
uh he questions what happened uh
so richard gage of architects and
engineers it's
large group there's uh balsamo
of the pilots for 9 11 truth they all
question that i've corresponded with all
of these people
how about the the people who have
lost loved ones the family members i'm a
family member trying to find out the
answers
to the murder of three thousand plus
people he's
looked at architects and engineers
people all around the world
scientists all around the world are
questioning this
we will never heal this country will
never ever
ever forget that day we have to demand
a new investigation i want justice here
um are they a part of this uh
questioning also many of them
they are and but it's so hard to get
hold of them it's
their their names aren't readily
available i don't have their phone i've
tried to get hold of them
to find out what happened to their loved
ones what bodies were recovered where
they were buried
because there's apparently some
uncertainty about all of that
especially when you get to examining
what happened with the plane
allegedly to obstruct the pentagon
and the one that alleged to have crashed
in that field in pennsylvania
the evidence shows that at the pentagon
there is no evidence of a boeing 757
crashing there
i am major general albert stubblebine
i am retired army major general
in my last assignment my last command i
was responsible for
all of the army's strategic intelligence
forces
around the world on september the 11th
in 2001
what hit the pentagon
i don't know exactly what hit it
but i do know from the photographs that
i have analyzed and looked at
very very carefully it was not an
airplane
in the field in pennsylvania whatever
was
fell there was blown out of the sky it
did not impact the earth but that story
about the
passengers struggling with the hijacker
that's all false
seems like geraldo you know geraldo he
had a change of he's a famous
uh yeah he's someone after he listened
to some of the family members and
the chief of architects and engineers he
had a change
of heart and what caught my eye as more
than 1300 architects and
engineers examined the evidence about
building seven's collapse
and disagree with the official report
issued by the national
institute of standards and technology i
certainly am much more open-minded about
it than i was
and it is because of the involvement of
the 911 families and all these engineers
and architects
yeah uh geraldo i saw one youtube video
where he changed his mind about it
the the biggest i think the one name we
haven't mentioned is professor david ray
griffin
professor david ray griffin was a
retired theologian from a california
university
and a philosopher and he had written 12
15 books on philosophy and theology
he came across these so-called
conspiracy theorists who was very
skeptical
but eventually he looked into it and
ended up writing
12 13 books on 9 11. uh he's 12 13 books
so he started off as a skeptic he didn't
believe any of this and probably was
calling people
crazy and deranged yeah and now he's
writing about global warming in the
environment
but i mean if you the person that's done
i think the
best research and written the most about
is david ray griffin
have things like this in the past happen
you have like uh was it
1964 the gulf of tonkin yeah
it's very common for major powers to lie
to their people to justify some military
action
the gulf of tonkin where the vietnamese
were alleged to have
shot at our ships i i think the uss
maddox if i remember correctly
that was a lie because lyndon johnson
is quoted to have said for all i know
they were shooting at wales
this is in the archives i got this out
of there
the other one more interesting or more
directly relevant
is the operation northwoods
operation northwoods was a plan proposed
by the joint chiefs of staff to
president kennedy
and what they said we we will shoot
americans on the streets here
we will fly a plane with americans
towards cuba
substitute it for an unmanned plane and
shoot down
and blame cuba so that they would have
an excuse to
attack cuba and make war on castro
so this is very common the pearl harbor
some say was of
well it wasn't a false flag but the
president knew it was coming
and let it happen so they could join the
war against japan
who benefits at the end if you look at
motive we don't have to bring on
sherlock holmes
to come in and look because obviously
this
goes against the teachings of islam this
has nothing to do with islam you
actually
can buy yourself a one-way ticket to the
hellfire by killing
one innocent human being you know islam
is clear on this you have
no justification in islam and that's why
when we look at as muslims those
who are trying to live in peace with
society with our creator
and this has only brought more harm to
islam and muslims
so there's no benefit there for for for
islam or muslims but who really at the
end benefits well
at the end the folks that benefit is the
military-industrial congressional
complex
uh now the so-called homeland security
complex
uh these are the guys benefiting they've
been benefiting for years president
eisenhower warned against the
military-industrial complex
uh before him there was a general
smedley butler
who received two congressional medals of
honor
like audie murphy when a lot of folks
know about audie murphy but they don't
know about smedley butler
because he talked about the real purpose
of their wars in south america and china
so this has been going on
which comes which brings us to the real
election today
none of the things that candidates are
promising to the american people
as opposed to the corporations can be
achieved unless you cut that military
budget
and that's what was proposed after the
collapse of the soviet union
uh the secretary of defense mcnamara and
his assistant secretary testified on the
hill
that the defense budget can be cut in
half over 10 years
that's what set off their
uh i guess alarm bells through the
military-industrial complex
and they had to come up with a plan to
keep them
to keep the defense spending and in fact
increase it so we're going to take a
break
the main question is now that we got one
down but there's so many more
but real simple one to remember who set
up the demo
the demolition let's let's we don't know
we don't know that's that's a big
question
let's take a break we'll be right back
with more here on the dean's show an
independent press
to try to get the word out to the public
because the public
is mesmerized by the mainstream media
and let me give you my
opinion of the mainstream media the
mainstream media
is uh their mission is is to act as
the most effective weapon of mass
deception
and public manipulation the world has
ever seen
and if you don't think that's so ask
anyone
any taboo question that the mainstream
media frowns upon
with its army of trusted celebrity
prostitutes all right and and
and you will see a sadly predictable
knee-jerk reactionary response
from the public because that's what
they've been trained to believe
and trust in subscribe right now
[Music]
back here on the dean show with the
author of 9 11
unveiled how many uh people get this for
free you said it's free just
just google 911 unveiled free and you'll
get to it how many downloads
over 75 over 75 okay now let me ask you
this
the war on islam you do you
wh why did you label the book the word
well uh
this book started out as just separate
articles
and the first article was as we were
attacking iraq the first time
and i wrote that article as the bombs
were falling and it was
the holocaust in iraq is what the title
was
and i continued writing it at some point
i
so or someone suggested why don't you
put this into a book so i did and i
thought of a catchy title
titles if they're wrong i couldn't write
the war for resources markets etc
so it was a war in islam i mean is that
really what we see going on today does
most muslims feel like well actually for
some it is a war on islam but for the
most part it's a war for resources and
markets
and that's what virtually every war we
america's fought or the war is fought by
other countries it's typically there for
access to resources and markets or
rather to control them
we don't necessarily need the oil we
want to control the oil just like the
drug dealer doesn't need the drugs he
wants to control the drugs
and that's what virtually every war is
about control of resources and markets
have you sat with some of these big
officials that questioned the official
story
have you talked with them have you um
i've tried to
none of them will i was at a small
gathering where the
chairman of the 911 commission uh the
wall street reporter on terrorism a
british expert on terrorism they were
sitting
as close as your cameras from me and i
at the end i
of the their talk i rose up and i said
mr mr chairman
are you aware that 3 000 plus architects
and engineers
questioned their official account in 9
11 and i have a little book
summarizing what i my research
and i said i'd like you to rebut it
and he said well i'll get back to you
later which is reasonable i didn't
expect him to
but none of them ever will get back to
you they say that
so that they have something in front of
the audience like their will
agreeing to respond to you but they
don't
in south africa when i was a like three
week lecture tour
giving two or three talks daily from
audiences of a hundred to a thousand
the national radio station would not put
beyond till somebody from the embassy
was there to
to rebut me but they waited and waited
eventually put me on because nobody
would
come forward now are you willing if
somebody have you had
um debates with anybody about this and
are you willing if someone invited you
to go on a platform
anybody from the administration to be a
spokesman for the administration account
for 9 11
and i will rebut it but what we have
here
if you were to look at that event as a
criminal act
you know in a criminal act if you do not
unable to rebut the evidence presented
then you lose the case right away so i'm
sorry go ahead yeah i think that's
called prima facie evidence so we have
primary fashion evidence
of muslims innocence and since the
government refuses
or rebutted under american law
they would be off as innocent what if
someone says okay
because i mean this is profound let's go
back again three thousand if
if we were saying just three thousand
laymen but these are
three thousand uh architects and
engineers who have
scientific forensic evidence these are
the experts in that area
why the official story uh the final
official account of 9 11
is unscientific and false
and i in that book
give a massive amount of evidence that's
been compiled by
scientists architects and engineers
that all three buildings
uh although in that book i focus on
world trade center seven
were brought down by explosives there's
simply no
other possibility and the only way that
nist
the national institute of standards and
technology which wrote the official
report
the only way they were able to deny that
was to commit
massive scientific fraud
which in simple words simply means they
lied they lied and they lied
i think it's unprecedented in america to
have so many professional
uh claiming that the official account is
a lot wrong
and the media not doing anything about
it story the times missed
building seven brought down to control
demolition i don't know whether it was
accomplished by a demolition expert or
it just happened
i did not know that never knew that
let's check out our billboard right up
there man
check it out thank you i actually where
was it that we were just at the airport
recently
and it had that on top of the taxi cab i
think there's something to it
because the buildings came down and they
weren't built
so that they would come down like that
not doing anything about it but it's
understandable
because uh 90 percent
of what you see watch listen to
or read is controlled by six
corporations in america
they control all that that's why and
they're the same ones
they're benefiting from the wars so you
don't expect them to undercut their own
store
source of income that's interesting okay
so you have on one end
you have a group of people benefiting so
many people just
they don't want to go against the grade
it's understandable they they're quiet
but over here on the other side these
people most people who are coming
forward
they're the ones who are going to get
rid of guilt they got more to lose
so many of them are risking their
employment to do that but
those are the people worth listening to
right right and
many of them are retired but the ones
that are risking their employment
i haven't really found the ones that are
risking their employment i've
i think most of the ones i've spoken
with are retired
and i'm retired but while i was on i was
approached by the news and i
i deferred from commenting so
but regardless i mean you have that many
professionals
disagreeing if you get some other issue
you have six professional two
professionals disagreeing and they're on
tv take any issue regarding israel
you see a handful of people protesting
and the media's covering it and you'll
have
thousands of muslims demonstrating in
washington the media doesn't cover it
so that's just the media's selectivity
now the people who also i mean their
motive
you look forward they they're really
there there's no motive but
at the end truth they want the truth
they want these questions answered the
architects and engineers the experts in
this field
for me there's a great personal
satisfaction to have completed
some kind of investigation and the
reception has gotten from the public
you know what so am i
do you work at the times i do so now
that you see it
what does that story mean to you it
means i gotta go to a meeting i think
it's
funny because i never cared about the
third tower
as evidenced by the downloads and
talking as
assignments etc for me there was that
great personal satisfaction
to be able to contribute on this major
issue
i have nothing to gain by it i set up
the wisdom fund in 1995 to
try to get the truth out about islam
yeah i draw a salary of one dollar a
year from that
wisdom fund so i definitely don't
benefit but the personal satisfaction is
priceless yeah that's something uh
people really can't understand when you
when you
uh it gives you confidence when you when
you have um
truth on your side evidence on your side
there's some some
some major confidence that it builds
isn't that right yeah
and just the little notes i get from
around the world
of appreciation and it just makes it all
worth it
give us uh we're almost out of time uh
maybe your top three questions that you
would ask
somebody in an authority that you want
answers to you don't have to obviously
answer them but from your investigation
and
what maybe these 3000 arctic
engineers give us one to three top
questions we answered
asking one who set up the demolition
that's just a fact there was a
demolition set up and uh
firemen have testified to it scientists
are engineers architects
that's unrefutable yeah i would say to
at the pentagon
show me hard evidence that the boeing
757
that you allege crashed there and that
evidence would be
serial numbers on the parts etc of that
plane uh
to uh you know about the world trade
center towers
explain to me how that tower could
possibly collapse
by the impact of a plane two thirds of
the way up
and the fire which basically was out of
steam within 15-20 minutes
there's no way before 9 11 no steel
frame high-rise had collapsed
after 9 11 none collapsed on that day
three collapse
which leads me to building a seven of
the world trade center a 47-story
building that about
5 20 i believe in the evening came down
suddenly
symmetrically how can that possibly
collapse show me a computer model
or something that'll show how that
collapsed
it's impossible without explosives
so those are the main questions and
people can actually vote for your books
they can download them for free yeah
just
google the title and include the word
free
and you'll get to it and this is the war
on islam and 9
11 unveiled they can get there for free
thank you very much
any closing comments that you like to uh
for the for the person who
you know at the end it takes some some
go ahead one closing comment
if you're a muslim ask your muslim
leadership
to examine this issue i'd be happy to
come out there and speak on it
i'll get you other speakers closer to
you to speak on it
but get with your interfaith community
and speak out on this issue
thank you very much we started with
peace we are with peace peace be with
you peace peace
there you have it another exciting
episode subscribe if you haven't already
remember
we started out in the beginning look a
muslim technically a muslim
is one who has consciously chosen to
submit to the creator
not the creation jesus moses abraham all
the messengers that the creator sent out
of his
love they were all ones who submitted to
the will of god now when you're
submitting yourself
as a muslim any peaceful person who does
this
and lives this peaceful way of life of
islam submission to the crater
not the creation they're not committing
acts of terrorism
they're not committing crimes against
humanity so from that perspective
done islam and muslims nothing to do
with such tragic events
as such but now 3 000 plus
architects and engineers are asking
some very important questions like
who set this up the demo and
firefighters and american patriots and
politicians who are coming forward who
have have
had a awakening of the consciousness
people who have looked into us
this a little bit deeper and who are not
just blindly following the official
stories
they're asking questions now
it's up to you you want to look into it
further go ahead
but we just brought this information to
you and you can do whatever you want
with it but our main objective here was
to
once again free islam that when you
think about islam you think about what i
thought about when i started to learn it
the love the mercy and the justice and
to have a new picture painted in your
mind
and to free you from any clouded vision
that you might
have some perverted vision about muslims
and islam because the more you study it
the more you will be free from thinking
that it had anything to do with
motivating people to do such
an evil act and if you like this program
subscribe right now
follow us every week here in the dean
show where you get to learn
a lot of great and interesting things
call us at 1-800-662-islam we have
people there who are
ready to answer your questions your
queries and until next time
peace be with you salaam lake subscribe
right now